There's a trajectory in the shows that
have done at Moma up in there,
it's almost 14 years and it's a
trajectory that is personal,
but that it's at the same time as
institutional,
you know,
from the beginning.
Moma has alternated in design very
historical exhibitions that are meant to
advance the scholarly field with
exhibitions that are instead and
programs that are instead about people's
lives,
about how design can improve people's
about,
uh,
issues that pertain to that particular
moment.
Just to give you an example,
you know,
Moma had a series in the 19 thirties
that was called good called good design
under $5,
$10,
blah,
blah blah during the war because you,
because people had no access to steel
and aluminum and other materials.
They did a show called good design in
times of war.
So it was always with an attention to
people's needs in my particular,
um,
career.
I tried always to look at both people's
lives and also technology advancements
in always this to this two spheres
coming together.
So the first show that I did in 95 was
called Newton materials and contemporary
design.
It was about a revolution in the way
materials were designed and implemented,
something that gave designers more power
to actually find to not only the objects
but also the materials,
so it was technology and it was life and
then I went on and did other shows.
Sorry,
can you cut in between?
Okay.
And then I went on and did other shows
that were about people's lives.
Just to give you an example,
in 2000 I did a show called work spheres
because@thattimeitwasthe.com boom.
It was the beginning of wireless
technology,
so there was a lot of excitement.
We all went,
almost were all drunk,
right?
With this kind of possibilities,
but at the same time wireless technology
was not really working.
We were always traveling with too many
plugs and then the plug didn't work.
The server at home did not connect.
We had to dial in.
I mean it was just hell.
So it was about wireless technology,
new possibilities and people's real
lives.
So it was all this new concepts for
working and traveling and so on and so
forth.
And about two years ago I did a show on
design and safety because safety has
become a really big concern,
you know,
the world has changed.
I don't need to explain,
it was something that was conceived
before nine slash 11,
but,
and it was topped by 9:11 because I
freaked out at that time and waited for
a long time.
So it was only two years ago,
but it was about design and safety.
Now I've come to the point that wireless
technology really works,
that we really are in communication with
many different parts of the world.
We work at different scales,
we work in different time zones on
screens,
have different resolutions.
We speak with people from all over the
world.
We are sometimes alone and sometimes in
the middle of the gigantic route we've
become much more elastic.
And uh,
um,
it's an about these possibilities,
new technologies and the connection
between design and science.
So it really is about us negotiating all
these changes and negotiating progress
with the help of design.